bag after bag
box after box
out of incredible suffering has come
this moving human kindness look have a
little cardigan
tom jackson and sister jenny hancock
have family in ukraine and set up this
aid collection point in a local workshop
for days now there's been endless
donations
it's been incredibly moving and we're
just really proud to be a part of it to
be honest we've been working with the
ukrainian center in manchester but at
the moment we've completely swamped them
out and now there they've got this
bottleneck now where they're struggling
to get things over to
to the ukraine
or even poland if there is some haulish
company out there who would be willing
to accept or accept the goods and get it
to the polish border where it's
desperately needed that would be just
what that would just be amazing we need
a trolley we've got the trolleys
people have been moved to act in ways
both big and small
charity dec saw 55 million pounds raised
in just 24 hours
this coffee shop is donating a day's
profits
[Music]
people are seeking ways to just act and
to to show kindness and i think that
just you know being able to purchase a
coffee and have a quick chat
but whilst doing good is so meaningful
to so many and it's overwhelming how
generous people are
generous and aware i loved the messages
of staying strong i've seen some
fantastic hope and
strength messages coming out through
those pupils at this manchester school
want ukrainian children to know they are
not forgotten children my age and
younger as well they're leaving it's
it's really sad and upsetting my message
that i put on the wall was for both
sides like russia and ukraine to choose
harmony instead of destruction
and um
to like for the people to stay strong
because
just imagine a week ago they were the
kids in ukraine were learning about
algebra and now the houses are being
born bombed
in a complex world walls can sometimes
divide
this one is all about
support catherine of autopsy sky news in
manchester